[Musique]
la Terre vue du ciel plus précisément le
Togo le Bénin la Namibie c'est le thème
de l'exposition commentée présentée par
l'association des ailes et des hommes le
1er décembre prochain à joir
Pontchartrin bonsoir Jean-Pierre Navaro
vous êtes photographe secrétaire de
cette association également vous
pratiquez le paramoteur cet aéronef qui
vous permet de prendre de la hauteur et
de réaliser donc différents clichés des
vidéos également l'aventure africaine
que vous allez présenter au public
samedi elle a commencé quand pour vous
et puis pourquoi également et bien
l'aventure africaine elle a commencé il
y a 5 ans je fais partie de d'une
association qui s'appelle des allés des
hommes et donc notre association à but
humanitaire nous permet lorsqu'on voyage
il y a un groupe qui fait de
l'humanitaire et un groupe qui qui
volons de pouvoir aller à la rencontre
des populations locales et également de
faire des dons parce que le but c'est
pas uniquement de réaliser des prises de
vue c'est effectivement de faire de
l'humanitaire sur ce voyage en Afrique
une dizaine de villages on ont pu être
tridé 80 traitements médicaux par
exemple aussi oui ce que l'on fait c'est
qu'on apporte à partir d'ici du des
petits matériels médical qu'on laisse
sur place et également pour faire vivre
tout l'écosystème sur place on achète du
matériel c'est par exemple de la
spiruline on avait acheté une centaine
de kilos de spiruline au Burkina Faso et
également au Bénin et on distribue à des
dispensaires et effectivement on aide
certaines personnes qui ont des carences
en fer par exemple de pouvoir prendre ce
complément alimentaire c'est c'est c'est
un exemple donc vous vouliez une passion
véritablement de pouvoir utiliser s
paramoteur et de pouvoir survoler
d'aussi beaux paysages et puis également
de l'humanitaire on en parlait vous êtes
venu avec aussi quelques photos que vous
avez pu réaliser sont posé sur ce
plateau on les apercevra peut-être tout
à l'heure mais je vais vous montrer
aussi quelquesunes des quelquesuns des
clichés que vous avez réalisé et qui
seront commentés également lors donc de
l'exposition qui est présentée à jou
Ponchartrain puis je vais vous laisser
nous nous parler un petit peu des des
clichés qu'on va pouvoir montrer si on
peut montrer la première des photos
alors à cet endroit où sommes-nous là
nous sommes au Bénin BAA donc ça sera
raconté effectivement le samedi à la
médiiathèque de joueurs Pontchartrain à
partir de 18h et là c'était notre
premier vol que nous avons fait là-bas
il nous est arrivé un certain nombre
d'histoires on avait pas demandé les
autorisations on s'est fait arrêter sur
place mais des vols vraiment superbes
là-bas donc et franchement c'est un
paysage idylique et on a pu aider
également certaines certaines écoles
également sur place j'ai encore deux
photos à vous montrer que vous vous
connaissez forcément vous avez réalisé
ces clichés avec l'association laibi
Moon landscape vraiment une terre on se
croirait sur la luneh ça c'est un
exemple effectivement je montrerai
également des vidéos samedi mais un
paysage en namiie extraordinaire et vous
avez rencontré les populations locales
bien sûr là aussi on va voir une toute
dernière photo oui elle été réalisée où
cette photo des enfants et là on est au
Bénin dans le nord du Bénin à côté du
parc du panjari et je sais pas si vous
en avez une ou deux effectivement aussi
en namibi on a on a rencontré les les
imba une population tout à fait
extraordinaire et quel accueil vous avez
eu là-bas justement quand vous êtes
arrivés avec les paramoteurs pour filmer
prendre des photos en fait il y a plus
la barrière du blanc et qui vient aider
également ça peut être un problème même
pour les associations c'est pas
forcément simple d'aider les populations
locales mais le fait de venir en
paramoteur sachant que c'est anecdotique
par rapport à notre aide humanitaire et
bien ça ça casse complètement toutes les
barrières qui sont qu'est-ce qu'ils font
là pourquoi ils ont du matériel ça coûte
cher et nous on n pas grand-chose
donc ça casse toutes les barrières et ça
nous permet d'être avec eux et de
discuter avec eux de façon la plus
simple possible et puis d'enchaîner
effectivement si on a à les aider de
pouvoir les aider tout tout simplement
sans et être avec eux c'est ça qui est
important et vous s'il y a un souvenir
que vous deviez conserver et ne jamais
oublier ce serait lequel en isoler he
oui euh peut-être la petite Sarah son
regard al on verra peut-être sinon je
vais essayer de de montrer ce cliché
voilà c'est e ça si ça ne brille pas
trop voilà VO donc c'est pouvoir aider
des personnes et le regarde des enfants
quand on va dans les orpholin pouvoir
les aider les accompagner ça ça c'est ce
que je prends avec moi c'est des clichés
qui seront vendus également lors de
l'exposition commentez oui c'est ça
juste après donc je je vais parler 30
minutes de cette aventure africaine de
des rencontres de la rencontre du roi
d'Agbodrafo c'est extraordinaire je vous
raconterai ça et ensuite en fait
j'expose une cinquantaine de de photos
imprimées sur du métal c'est du Dibon et
je vends effectivement ces photos entre
50 € et plus c'est un don et c'est
exonéré d'impôt 60 et ça permet de
récolter des fonds pour l'association
parce qu'on imagine qu'il y a d'autres
opérations de ce type qui vont avoir
lieu par la suite absolument le prochain
c'est on a déjà une équipe de notre
association sachant que nous sommes des
bénévoles j'ai un autre travail par
ailleurs mais des personnes qui sont à
la retraite qui font partie de
l'association qui sont partis qui sont
en Argentine donc on est en train
d'évaluer l'aide qu'on peut apporter
là-bas sur place rien n'est planifié
avant on voit sur place uniquement et
puis en mars j'irai en Argentine dans le
Nord pour pouvoir aider et accompagner
on va va quitter l'Afrique on va
profiter de votre présence sur ce
plateau pour parler d'un autre projet et
les clichés les vidéos que vous allez
apercevoir vont peut-être vous sembler
plus familières ça été réalisé du côté
de trappe vous avez travaillé pour la
municipalité pour l'association toujours
pour réaliser quelques photos de de la
ville dans quel but a eu lieu cette
cette opération on voit quelques clichés
qui ont été fait ça c'est c'est un très
beau projet qui date il y a 2 ans j'en
avais parlé à un ami euh pierre le dos
qui habite à trape j'ai habité moi-même
une vingtaine d'années à trapppe traape
on en parle de façon souvent assz
péjorative et je vu de làhaut trappe ça
donne une autre dimension et je pense
que ça vaut le coup de montrer ces
villes à problème mais aujourd'hui
trappe s'en sort vraiment très très bien
quand on prend la hauteur on voit pas
tout à fait les mêmes choses voilà et
c'est une très très belle ville son lac
lac de Saint-Quentin peut-être personne
l'a vu de cette façonl c'est une ville
qui est très très verte qui est très
belle même les changeurs je c'est très
graphique c'est une ville qui est très
très graphique une ville qui est en qui
est en en pleine évolution en pleine
mutation vue de là-haut également ce
qu'on peut voir voyez c'est très très
vert et je pense que ça valait le coup
de le montrer et en parlant à à à Pierre
à Annie Leir qui éta élu à guimandin si
lui est remonté directement il a aimé le
projet et il a souhaité que au titre de
l'association dont je fais partie
pouvoir faire ses photos et ses vidéos
et donc le maire de la ville qui pour
l'instant a récupéré ses photos qui
seront ensuite présenté normalement lors
de ses vœux sans doute d'ici d'ici la
fin de l'année forcément pour pour
célébrer le passage à l'année 2013 les
vidéos sonont à quel usage on peut les
découvrir où si le public veut les voir
alors des et deseshommes.org il y a
toutes les photos que ça soit d'Afrique
ou que ça soit effectivement de Trapp
deses et deseshommes.org et je rappelle
la principale le principal pardon
rendez-vous que vous proposez le 1er
décembre l'aventure africaine vue du
ciel c'est à la médiathèque de joir
Pontchartrain samedi 1er décembre dès
18h et votre site internet vous l'avez
mentionné merci d'être venu donc sur ce
planau nous parler de cette opération
nous allons nous intéresser à l'Europe
et à l'économie ce son les deux
thématiques qui nous intéresser pour la
suite du 78 et on va commencer par
l'économie